in recent years some of the world's
biggest companies have discarded depth
and detail to dbrand
burger king lost weight
rolling stone found a cleaner edge vw
shared its depth and shadow as did kia
fizer nissan
durex intel toyota and a host of other
major brands
even the munchable hero julius pringle
had a flattening make under with shaved
head dyed mustache dilated eyes and new
pre-sprung eyebrows
but what prompted this landslide of logo
deep branding
several interlocking forces are at work
the most immediate of which is the
pressure of mobile first design
clients used to ask can you make the
logo bigger now the trick is to shrink
an entire identity into a tiny digital
box
such pixel pressure usually means
returning to the 2d look of old of
course this 2d look was more or less the
norm until computers took over and
design inflation spiraled out of control
anyone who has overfiltered an instagram
sunset knows the seductive lure of
visual excess and it's a seduction to
which the pros are not immune
the ability to round corners drop
shadows customize gradients and create
complex lighting effects can easily
overpower the creative brief and often
does
so many recently brands represent a
return to sobriety after a spasm of
software-rebetted intoxication there was
also the question of maturity many of
our biggest brands were born in a spirit
of playful innocence that burst forth
from their early branding take
foursquare airbnb
godaddy google as these companies grew
and the stakes rose so their logos were
obliged to mature from cartoonish to
corporate flamboyant to flat wacky to
bland
illustrating the power of de-branding to
professionalize
and then there is fashion
company graphics are as susceptible to
trends as any other design as we see in
the stampede of fashion's little black
dress logos heralded by issan laura in
2012 and followed by diane von
furstenberg calvin klein berluti
burberry and baumein yet the most
intriguing element of the d branded logo
is its potential to become a portal
warner brothers didn't just strip back
its theatrical golden guilt it unlocked
a world of possibility that's
increasingly vital to brands that span
genres showcase variety or offer 31
flavors
for all these reasons it seems likely
that d branding will be with us for a
while but who knows when the pendulum
will swing and the trend revert to
detail complexity and personality after
all once a critical mass is zagged
against the prevailing zig the margin
becomes mainstream the template flips
and the dance begins afresh
i'm ben shot the branding and
advertising columnist for bloomberg
opinion
[Music]